[Music]
that's the new PFT p.m. open we're gonna
start playing at four PFT ot since the
PFT ot audio file ends up in the PFT PM
podcast what was that what was I didn't
hear them what was it well you'll hear
the next time it's a new open it's good
it's got some sound bites some of my
favorite quotes of all time and nothing
like nothing about you though it's not a
game we're not making fun of you yet no
I didn't think we could in the future
but eventually you know for now we're
good alright let's get into it today
this is these are the things that either
we want to continue or elaborate on from
PFT live or things we didn't get to and
I want to get back to handshake gate we
talked about how Baker Mayfield will or
should or could handle the situation
when he meets with the media today at
some point Richard Sherman's going to be
talking to reporters again how should he
handle it and how will he handle well I
mean I always go to like let's just say
the truth I mean that that's always the
best way to handle any situation and
maybe say that you know hey listen yeah
he did shake my hand and maybe I went a
little too far with some of my criticism
and things I said on Twitter and in
doing that I do still wish he would have
shook my hand after the coin toss he
could certainly still say that but I
think he needs to kind of take some of
the the blame or the brunt you know just
some of the distraction here upon
himself to say you know what I went a
little too far with this and I let it
get out of hand I think that would be
the proper thing to do I don't know if
he would do that though it doesn't seem
like that's something that he normally
does so I'm gonna be interested to see
how he handles it in general and I agree
with you he should reside within the
boundaries of the truth but for the past
what 24 plus hours he hasn't right and I
don't expect him to do it I think he's
gonna blame others he'll blame the media
for making it a big deal he'll blame the
media for mischaracterizing what
happened I'll be curious to see whether
or not he blames Mike silver for not
telling the story the way that it was
told it wouldn't be the first time that
that accusation has been
against Mike silver accurately or
incorrectly because I'm familiar of
three or four other occasions at least
over the years where someone has had
their quotes come to light and they've
said I didn't say that or I didn't say
it that way right so to be interesting
to see if he turns on him but he's not
gonna take the blame here and and this
continues to be one of the stupidest
things I've ever seen and the guy went
to Stanford and people in the media
praised him all the time he's a smart
guy he went to Stanford he may be a
smart guy but this whole thing was dumb
and it shows a lack of self-awareness it
shows a lack of understanding of how the
world works because you can't make that
accusation that there was a snub of a
handshake without understanding that
there's going to be video out there that
debunks you and when he doubled down
yesterday yes yes still frame of that
first video that came out right it did
not conclusively show the handshake and
said he didn't shake my hand when the
next video that comes out shows he shook
his hand something's off yeah it was off
there well and that makes me think that
he's not gonna take responsibility he's
gonna find a way to blame somebody else
and that's gonna breathe new life into
it we'll probably be talking about it
tomorrow if Sherman ends up talking the
media to that
yeah well agreed I mean I just hope he
doesn't do that I hope we like you said
I mean this is a smart individual I mean
this is just a dumb ass yeah I mean I
gives it I don't you know yes I there's
a lot of smart people that go to
Stanford there's a lot of dumb people
that get into you know respected
institutions of higher learning well I
think that you know like ego and
stubbornness sometimes lead him down the
wrong wrong like road but I don't think
this is a dumb person by any stretch of
the imagination and here's what I think
it is I think it is yeah I think he's
smart but he's not smart enough to
realize that everyone else isn't dumb I
think that's what it well maybe that Dec
that's well said okay I'm not saying
that's not a possibility either but
again just you know own up to it Richard
Sherman you made a mistake you made a
big deal out of something that should
not have been such a big distraction
after your team just went for now it
does look attention-seeking and I wish
he'd I hope he does handle it you know
from the angle of the truth and admit he
was wrong and then also admit that I
understand even though I don't like the
Baker Mayfield didn't shake my hand I
also understand what it's like to kind
of be a young brash player in the NFL I
did some things early on in my career
that weren't deemed real professional
I've learned from those things you know
I think something like that would do do
him a lot more good than bad this could
get ugly though because if he gets
peppered with questions on a topic that
he doesn't want to talk about because he
knows there's no good way out of his
maze remember the time he threatened the
reporters credential in Seattle remember
that yeah I'd forgotten about that I
mean he's got he's got a mean streak to
him and and it comes out from time to
time and if he gets asked a bunch of
questions about this today and he
doesn't want to answer them because he
knows there's no good way to answer them
and without making it worse we could see
a little bit of a flash of anger I think
we're more likely to see anger from him
then we are from Baker Mayfield but I'm
gonna be very interested to see how both
of those guys handle it today yeah I am
too the last thing two that we really
haven't hit on this aspect of it you
know DeForest Buckner has been thrown
into this conversation through Richard
Sherman's tweets and things as well so
now he threw himself in he said he got
snubbed and he clearly didn't so he did
okay that's what I wasn't sure about I
wasn't sure if DeForest Buckner had
owned up to it himself so he said that
as well yeah so they're both gonna have
to answer these questions well and and
it's yet we talk about distractions and
your buddy Kyle Shanahan's got a
distraction on his hands now because
it's fodder for discussion with Richard
Sherman DeForest Buckner George Kimmel
who was there and it's and this is what
makes it even weirder the the article
from Mike silver downplayed
significantly the interaction between
Mayfield and Kido like it was a quick
hand slap when you see the video he
hugged it a hug so look look I've always
said it and I'm gonna say it again
there's an agenda there that Mike silver
has against Baker Mayfield and and and
he can get pissed about it that we're
saying so but the bottom line is don't
act out on your agendas and be
transparent and also don't let it affect
you like if there's somebody you don't
like you they got an army of reporters
at NFL Network get somebody else
involved it's gonna be negative about
Baker Mayfield or have somebody else to
serve as your conscience to make sure
that you are
taking into account that you have a bias
and you're going out of your way to be
fair so your own bias your likes and
your dislikes don't come into play it's
not that hard to do no it's not that
hard to do you just have to be willing
to do it
yeah all right next topic the forty
niners from a football standpoint caller
use check their full-back is out four to
six weeks with a knee injury we saw that
running game firing on all cylinders
Chris 275 yards on Monday night there
was that first play of the game where
Matt Breda was shot out of a cannon it
was a Kidal block and a used truck block
that popped him how difference is the
different is this offense with you stick
out for 46 yeah no this is this is a big
blow I mean again the the big thing is
Kyle Shanahan is one of the most
creative guys in the game and he's gonna
find ways to use other guys creatively
but he is a mismatch kind of nightmare
for defenses and how Kyle Shanahan uses
them because oh he's tight end he's
fullback he's a really good route runner
so you can line him up in the slot and
he can be matched up against you know
linebackers and safeties to where it's a
mismatch in those type of situations too
but really that's where you know the
there's always a few game planned
designs for Kyle you check on a weekly
basis where he comes out of fullback and
sneaks through you know the mosh pit
between the tackles and they have a
creative past design for him let alone
he's a good blocker and does all those
things really well too so yeah I mean
Hertz certainly can they find ways to do
things without him yes but I think he is
a big part of what makes them so
dangerous on the offensive side of the
ball because of that mismatch in
personnel what is it is that are they
gonna pass they gonna run it's gonna be
power run game those are the kind of
kind of you know issues he puts on the
defense and you look every team's got to
deal with injuries at some point the
49ers have been more unlucky than others
in recent years especially with Jimmy
Garoppolo last year but if you're a
49ers fan and you start worrying about
things that could derail what could be a
special season injuries can do it it's
done it before with other teams it's
done before with the 49ers
right the New England Patriots not
because of injury but because of
retirement and ultimately lack of a
roster spot they're down Rob Gronkowski
they're down Ben Watson at tight end
it's Matt Lacoste
and Ryan is oh who are left at the
position and Tom Brady was asked about
how he feels about the tight ends that
are on the team and he said yesterday at
a press conference I'm the quarterback I
don't make those decisions whoever's out
there that's who I've got to play with
not exactly a ringing endorsement for
Lacoste and Izzo I you know how big of a
concern is this that we're down to a
couple of guys who no one is going to
confuse with George Kittel or Travis
Kelce or Rob Gronkowski or any great
tight ends no I mean again they're gonna
use the tight ends they're just not
gonna be as a big a part of the passing
game as we've seen in years past or just
the the week to week game planning where
they were so integral over the last 10
years for the New England Patriots but
you know we've seen them survive did you
say intrical and it is I might have said
that yes that doesn't into integral
integral integral yes I did yeah thank
you totally threw me off face there but
so I've seen them you know adapt to life
without Aaron Hernandez and Rob
Gronkowski and Gronkowski being hurt you
know there's we've had enough evidence
to go well they find ways to find a new
formula that works for their offense
whether that's just you know
incorporating the backs in the past game
more but they find different personnel
sets and they'll find the mismatches
that they deem necessary through their
study and breakdowns in a week to week
basis to where you know I'm not worried
about it I don't think it's an issue
they overcome obstacles on a yearly
basis in New England with game planning
and things like that and always seemed
to do the right thing
I still wonder whether or not Tom
Brady's gonna pick up the phone make a
call to Rob Gronkowski at some point to
get him to come back and I was told back
in July that that will be a factor if a
personal plea comes from Brady to Gronk
then that's when Gronk could spring into
action do you have to gain some weight
the calls gonna have to come sooner
rather than later because he has to be
ready to go by the Tuesday after week 13
to join the active roster but if the
seeds gonna be planted Chris I think the
over-under is Halloween and who knows
with Antonio Brown gone and Tom Brady
wasn't happy about that reportedly he
didn't seem to be happy about Ben Watson
not being part of the team
III think that you know they probably
are good enough defensively to get to
where they want to be without Gronk but
I think Gronk is that little icing on
the cake that that increases your
likelihood that you can get back to the
Super Bowl and win it because look at
the big catches he made in the AFC
Championship game and in the Super Bowl
you don't even do anything in the
regular season yeah just have him ready
to go for the playoffs well yeah that's
where I mean he certainly can can make a
big difference but I mean as it looks
right now I don't see it happening I
don't I mean I I saw another picture of
Gronk the other day and I feel like he
even lost a few more pounds from the
last time we were talking about it
looked like he looked skinny and lost a
few pounds plus he just signed that deal
with Fox News
I mean Fox News thought that would be an
interesting connect with me that would
be yes so many things I could say right
now but I won't go there either way yes
yeah I mean he judges that with Fox
Sports that just is another inkling to
me though that here we are you know
early October that his mind is not on
football and then it's somewhere else
right now so I don't see it happening
well it's definitely on football if he's
going to be part of the Fox Sports NFL
coverage and he makes his debut Thursday
night for the Giants Patriots game he'll
be part of the pregame coverage here's
the quote from Gronk right I'm extremely
excited to be joining Fox Sports for the
past 25 years they've offered viewers
top-notch NFL programming from the field
to the booth to the studio they're deep
talent roster is unmatched which was
important for me as I embark on this new
chapter in my life because I'll be able
to learn from the best in the business
sounds like there is no way he wrote
that quote there is no way he read that
quote these are words he would never use
why do we insist on these people and
this is to all the PR personnel out
there when you are drafting these goofy
press conferences that no one ever reads
although you know what I mean press
releases we read this one because the
quote was so ridiculous so mission
accomplished this is just so ridiculous
this is not Gronk and it's just it's
just funny it
I wonder if they did that on purpose
knowing that it was going to be received
as there's no way in hell Gronk would
say that and that's the joke and if
that's the case I think it's brilliant
well I don't think that's the case
because I think we've got just as much
oh that stupid vigil everybody got just
as much attention if they just used a
really raw literal quote from Rob
Gronkowski it would have been like oh oh
it's cool I'm working with Fox Sports
and I get to talk to football and stuff
and I'm on TV and stuff I'm really
excited about it that would have got us
to read it as well so I don't think they
definitely planned that
yeah and find a way to work in like my
only regret the show is in 69 minutes
long or some sort of thing that Gronk
would think is hilarious you know I mean
so all right on we go I I get
transcripts all the time especially
middle of the week
coaching transcripts player transcripts
coordinator transcripts and the Eagles
are very good about sending out detailed
transcripts of press conferences which
is good and bad because then I got to
skim them and I was looking through Mike
Grows transcript yesterday the offensive
coordinator for the Philadelphia Eagles
and I noticed some questions about
Andrew send a hoe had been with the
Vikings for eight years
Eagles play the Vikings this weekend
send a house now in Philadelphia and
grow admitted that they're gonna talk to
him they're gonna talk to him about
whatever they can pick up about Mike
Zimmer's defense you've been part of
this preparation process how useful is
it to have someone in the locker room
who played for your upcoming opponent
who knows things about the offense of
the defense that the other team runs
yeah no it is useful I mean the coaches
can find out little context clues
through the coaching or the coaching of
a guy that has come from a you know a
prior team that you're about to face and
with a guy like Andrews and a hoe you
know especially playing the safety
position for that Minnesota Vikings
defense you know safety is like a
de-facto quarterback almost on an NFL
defense you know they have to know
everything the secondary and then of
course because they're in the box or the
run game they understand what's going on
up front they make calls on the back end
and what really I would think that Doug
Peterson and might grow end up doing
more than anything is okay hey what are
these checks you know they might look at
some hands thing
oh they're checking to this here so
Minnesota better would be alert to
change some hand signals and things like
that he's also gonna know just some
tendencies of like what Mike Zimmer
likes to do oh okay there's three
receivers to the left and one to the
right here's the defense a call and then
let's just say one of those three
receivers to the left emotions across
the line is you know across the ball to
the other side to now where it's two and
two he's gonna be able to say oh they're
making this type of call here because
they're worried about this this and this
so there is gonna be some understanding
of why they make the calls and then the
rules in which their coach to where the
Eagles are just hoping maybe two or
three plays during the game this can
come about to where they might be able
to steal a big play in a big moment or
design a big play to gash a defense and
it is certainly helpful all it takes is
one moment to change a game if I'm at
the right time you unleash that little
trick that thing that you're holding
back that thing you know about and off
we go we got a run Chris we'll check out
your new on button podcast coming later
today joint PFT p.m. on button coming
tomorrow everybody have a great day
there playing music to get me to shut up
shut up Florida has to do it leave
see ya later
you